hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number 138 we are
your dark horses in residence i am dr
brett weinstein this is dr heather heing
we have suffered a uh technological
malfunction but have recovered
splendidly i will say oh so splendid
splendidly
um
i was going to warn people
that although i feel great i have a
lingering cough from whatever it is that
got me which tested three times negative
for covet so i don't think it was
covered but anyway lingering cough
please bear with us if i end up coughing
in the middle of a concept
and uh dial up your level of inference
you may be able to finish my thought for
me in your head i know that sounds crazy
but it can happen
and
with that
let us
orient the audience to where we are
headed
we are going to talk today about
authoritarians and fiats
and science and scientific misconduct
and organizations that say that they
exist to provide accurate data and not
to propose policy and yet manage to
sneak in the ideology du jour
into what they write and produce and it
causes a person a thinking person i
think to
to wonder
what actually is possible like how
how ideology free how opinion free how
feelings free if you will
can
factual representation of
un currently understood to be true
things be
in in 2022 when social media in large
part although there are many other
factors as well
is
is working hard to make it very
difficult to know what is true and
what's not
are we still are we still live zach
okay
okay
all right
so
you
okay
okay
um
okay i don't know what's going on um i i
just have to check in zach we got a lot
of glitchy stuff here on our screen
[Music]
that means nothing at all okay
so probably to the relief of some people
listening right now we're not going to
be back next saturday we are not going
to be here there will be another podcast
that brett is doing with uh with a guest
that will be up uh at the same time so
uh that will that will keep you thinking
hopefully
and we will be doing a live q a after
today's stream if
if the technology allows you can ask
questions at darkhorsesubmissions.com
we
are live on both
odyssey and youtube as far as i know the
chat is live on odyssey at the moment
we have some cool stuff for sale at
darkhorsestore.org
where you can find various products like
epic tabbies and direwolves and
and jabs
at pfizer
yes and youtube and other things
we uh i always encourage you to find our
book hunter gatherers guide to the 21st
century and to find natural selections
which is my sub stack where i have
weekly ish
postings on various topics that are um
you know
widely
widely dispersed in topic but like what
we talk about here on darkhorse
uh basically if it um
if it evolved it's fair game and that
includes just about everything and we
even talk about some things that don't
evolve we occasionally talk about rocks
but not very often quasars yeah i i
don't think we've ever talked about
quasars i have
on dark horse uh sort of ocean you know
yeah i don't think you have i think
you're just trying to come up with
things that don't evolve which of course
yes that's true with quasars but i don't
think we've ever talked about them here
all right folks if you remember where it
is that i
mentioned quasars sota voce or not sota
voce or otherwise please feel free to
introduce that information into our into
our sphere in the comments or or
wherever yes
okay so we are supported by our audience
uh we appreciate you subscribing to the
channel
liking sharing both our full episodes on
youtube and odyssey and of course the
clips at darkrise podcast clips
uh and
we
encourage anyone who can afford to to
support us not just by sharing our work
but also by contributing to our patreons
where within a few minutes of us
finishing here today i will
set up the question asking period on my
patreon for our private monthly q a
which is a lot of fun it's smaller than
these from these chats with our live
streams and so we actually get to
interact with the chat brett just had a
conversation on his patreon this morning
which uh i assume as always went really
well i believe it did we are
dialing in a model for the admixture
between acting and planning
acting and planning
all right
and
uh and at both of our patreons you can
get access to our discord community
where
there's a lively community of people who
do not have any intention of canceling
you for having opinions that are
different from theirs and they do things
like book clubs and virtual karaoke and
are actually planning um a real-life
meetup they've done a couple but a real
life meetup in the pacific northwest at
the end of the summer
i have an error correction several
sentences ago i said between acting and
planning that's not what i meant it
falsely represents the coalition of the
reasonable group okay uh acting and
preparing
that is to say for future action
okay all right
i feel better now do you a little
so uh at the discord community uh you
i'm just gonna stop
okay you have any more corrections
we'll see okay
um we do encourage you to join to to
join that community and join us on our
patreons um this is going to be a tough
a tough day clearly um i am going to
start with our sponsors for the week for
which we are very very very
grateful this is the wrong set of papers
there's no one to blame for that but
myself okay now i have the correct set
of papers we have three sponsors as
usual and uh we don't do not take uh ads
we do not run ads for products that we
don't actually vouch for so we really do
feel extraordinarily positive about
thesis ned and md hearing aid our three
sponsors for this week
our first sponsor this week is new to us
this summer and it is thesis
thesis makes no tropics
nope no tropics no tropics are nutrients
found in nature or in the human body
which have been demonstrated to enhance
mental performance in areas such as
motivation creativity mood memory focus
and cognitive processing they work best
when combined with exercise proper
nutrition and mindfulness activities
such as meditation you're probably
already using enotropic as one of the
most commonly consumed no tropics is
caffeine but it is far from the most
exciting
tropics allow people to optimize their
focus energy and mood based on the
demands of the day in some cases no
tropics can replace the pharmaceuticals
that are usually used to tackle a
problem like adhd
thesis is unusual on the no tropic
market and taking a very personalized
approach they do not assume that what
works for your brother will work for you
or that what worked for you when you
were under deadline for a driver project
will be the same thing that will work
when you need a spark of creativity for
a project you've been dreaming about for
years for instance
just as some people become alert after a
cup of coffee and others fall right
asleep so too do all nodotropics have
different effects on different people
when the first with the first iteration
of thesis products customers were
treated like subjects in a clinical
trial blinded customers took a series of
different notropic blends over the
course of a month and reported how they
felt
analysis of that feedback found that not
surprisingly different people respond
differently to different blends now
after two years 2500 customers and
millions of data points thesis is
confident that they have created a
recommendation algorithm to predict
which blends of notropics will work best
for any given customer and the process
is simple go to their website take a
short quiz and they'll send a starter
kit with four different blend
recommendations to try over the course
of a month
i've now tried five of their blends two
of them have not been for me while three
have been intriguing and definitely
worth returning to two of which i have
the creativity blend for instance seems
to smooth things over add a little
clarity and make inspiration come a bit
easier and the logic blend seems to
facilitate focus and allow for getting
lots of tasks done with fully
personalizable blends there is likely to
be a thesis that is right for you
to get your own customized thesis
starter kit go online to takethesis.com
tarcourse take the quiz and use code
darkhorse at checkout for 10 off your
first box
okay our second sponsor this week is ned
a cbd company that stands out in a
highly saturated cbd market
ned was started by two friends who
discovered their hyper modern lives were
leaving them feeling quote empty
bewildered and disconnected something
about this way of life they say on their
website just wasn't working so they
started ned
you can buy cbd products in nearly every
coffee shop or grocery store but ned's
blends stand out they're de-stress blend
in particular really impressed us ned's
de-stress blend is a one-to-one formula
of cbd and cbg made from the world's
purest full spectrum hemp and also
features a botanical infusion of
ashwagandha cardamom and cinnamon
cinnamon
it's not actually how you say that but
i'm going to go with it
they could catch on
would you say
could catch on
cbg is known as the mother of all
cannabinoids and because of how
effective it is at combating anxiety and
stress by inhabiting the reuptake of
gaba the neurotransmitter responsible
for stress regulation
many of the cbd companies out there
source their hemp from industrial farms
in china but just like with low quality
alcohol low quality cbd can have
undesired effects net is usda certified
organic all of ned's full spectrum hemp
oil is extracted from usda certified
organic hemp plants grown by an
independent farmer named jonathan in
peonia colorado
also ned shares their third party lab
reports and information about who farms
their products and their extraction
process on their site
these products are science-backed
nature-based solutions that offer an
alternative to prescription and
over-the-counter drugs they're chock
full of premium cbd and a full spectrum
of active cannabinoids terpenes
flavonoids and trichomes now it's full
spectrum hemp oil nourishes the body's
endocannabinoid system to offer
functional support for stress sleep
inflammation and balance if you'd like
to give ned a try darkhorse listeners
get 15 off dead products with code
darkhorse visit helloned.com
darkhorse to get access that's
h-e-l-l-o-n-e-d
dot com slash dark horse to get 15 off
we thank ned for sponsoring the show and
offering our listeners a natural remedy
for some of life's most common health
issues
our final sponsor this week is md
hearing aid empty hearing aid was
founded by an ent surgeon who made it
his mission to develop a quality hearing
aid that anyone could afford recognizing
that about 95 of the people who need a
hearing aid only require a few settings
he removed some of the less often needed
components he also cut out the middleman
and now md hearing aid makes a
rechargeable hearing aid that is fda
registered and costs a small fraction of
what the typical hearing aid costs
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours their volt plus is water
resistant in up to three feet of water
and you don't need a prescription to get
one you buy it directly from the source
where audiologists and licensed hearing
specialists are available seven days a
week
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and here's what
she said
with my particular type of hearing loss
a deep male
voice is in a noisy room is the hardest
situation for me to hear and understand
i wore the md hearing aid to have a
conversation with a deep voice man in a
room with a lot of white noise the md
hearing aid passed the test as my
conversation partner's voice was clear
and understandable at a price point of
under a thousand dollars i was amazed at
how effective they are
md hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers plus they offer a 45-day
risk-free trial with a hundred percent
money-back guarantee
get clinical level care for eighty
percent less with md hearing aid go to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids costs
just
149.99 plus dark horse listeners receive
a free extra charging case 100 value so
head to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids for
149.99
[Music]
so
[Music]
perhaps our technical difficulties are
in the rearview mirror that would be
great that would be great and we are
ready to
to discuss some of the topics of the day
it has been a strange week uh in the
world
and also in our world
and so uh we just have we have a number
of things we might want to say something
about and if
if this makes sense i was thinking that
you might lead us off
uh
by talking a little bit about
what has happened to salman rushdie yes
what has happened to salman rushdie is
um
i think shocking to every thinking
person and another level it's something
which has a history
leading up to it of 33 years
salman rushdie was attacked this week
prior my understanding is to giving a
talk
in new york
and he was gravely injured i believe he
is expected to survive but
might lose an eye and has serious damage
which will
impact him
from here on through his life
this is
presumably the result
of a fatwa issued 33 years ago by
ayatollah khomeini
based on the fact that he had apparently
delivered a offense to allah
in the satanic verses a book of fiction
that he
he penned and he has lived under that
threat courageously for all of those
decades and uh i learned in looking into
that fatwa that apparently there is a
monetary reward offered it was increased
in in 2012
several million dollars
that has been offered for a person who
eliminates him it was never lifted and
uh several of the translators of his
work into other languages were attacked
and um i believe a couple of them were
killed
so you know even even translating the
work is deemed worthy of um
it's deemed a mortal offense
yes and
although
the iranian government has distanced
itself from the fatwa the monetary
reward
was raised by a semi-official entity
connected so this is really a
fundamental question about how the world
is to be run
what is within the purview of a
nation-state and
what is not
it is also well worth noting as many
people have
that there is some comparison to be made
between uh this
violent act and cancel culture and of
course one comparison that could be made
is that cancel culture in which you are
simply stigmatized and ostracized and
maybe driven from your chosen profession
is certainly preferable to being
attacked by a knife-wielding madman
but
there is a way in which this is a
difference in degree but not in kind
these are both
instances
in which people are preferring a system
in which what may be said and what may
not be said is dictated
by some authority and that
those limits should
guide discourse and be severely punished
when they are
violated
and
there is an alternative of course which
is the alternative upon which the west
is based in which individuals are free
to think and to say
essentially anything now of course there
are limits worth talking about but in
the realm of ideas in the realm
of narratives should you be free to
express anything and
be challenged if what you have said
is uh
vile or dangerous but not be silenced
and of course
this is in one way counter-intuitive
because
everyone who believes that certain
things are right in whatever way things
can be right and other things are wrong
would of course prefer a world of
the rightness flourishing and the
wrongness
being
absent but the problem is as the
american founders correctly realize the
truth is counter-intuitive that even
though most ideas that are expressed are
probably at best valueless and very
frequently wrong and sometimes downright
dangerous the most dangerous thing is an
environment in which you cannot express
ideas that are not sanctioned because
that is a world in which there can be no
progress
now there's a world frozen in some state
it's it's the frozen-ness really which
uh
which i think is what many people who
uh think that free speech should go by
the wayside
are are not recognizing it is it is also
the height of hubris
it is an arrogance that comes of
imagining that now finally after however
long it is that you want to keep track
of in the past finally we have arrived
in a moment of perfect understanding
and whereas we can all look back on
previous moments and say oh weren't they
confused weren't they small-minded
weren't they ignorant didn't they not
know the things that we know now
it imagines that we are now
omnipotent and omniscient
and that we have full possession of not
just the knowledge but also the power
and therefore that we want the full
possession of the power
to make sure that everyone who doesn't
yet see things as clearly as we do
uh can be forced to be relegated to um
to basically be our underlings
so i wanted to try to put this in
context of a model that long time
listeners of dark horse will have
interacted with many times in many
different contexts
in the comparison between
fatwa culture and cancel culture you
could view them as uh distinct and one
preferable over the other
or you could view them as the same thing
in a different form but the purpose is
to make sure that what is accepted is
accepted by fiat rather than by some
process in which we all participate
and
here's the thing that i think needs to
be explored
one of these
is obviously religious
right it is by religious authority that
the fatwa on salman rushdie was issued
and the other
of these is nominally secular
yes
that is the wrong way to think about it
though it is true at a factual level but
it is untrue at a deeper level
and what i would argue is that we come
all of us irrespective of what lineages
we emerge from we all come from a world
of religious authority every lineage has
that feature up until some point at the
least and some of them continue to
happen
those religious authorities
are
the result
of an evolutionary process
and
what i've argued many times and i'm
going to argue here again
is that you cannot found a religion in
the same way that you cannot write a
myth
you can write a narrative and then
selection can act upon narratives
throwing about throwing out almost all
of them relatively quickly after they
are written preserving a few that have
some kind of value and then honing them
and turning them into durable myths yes
and the same thing can be said
of a religion you cannot found a
religion
you can found something that functions
on those modalities which i would say is
correctly understood to be a cult and
then a very tiny fraction
of those cults turns out to have some
sort of durability lasting power
and uh
capacity to in some way or other enhance
the lives of uh believers and adherents
yeah and you know cult
always has a negative valence to a
negative connotation but
if we try to put that aside for them
what you're arguing is that a story with
staying power can become myth a cult
with staying power can become religion
but at its uh and its origin neither a
story nor a cult has the capacity to at
once at its inception call itself either
myth or religion right
i apologize um so what i'm what i'm
getting at i agree with the point about
the negative valence i think we need to
stop you having a negative valence for
uh
cults and stories and we need to think
about them in terms of the chances that
that one is a durable one are very very
low so our skepticism of both things
right a story can be entertaining but
what are the chances that a story is
valuable well if we know nothing about
the content of the story it's very low
and
the same thing for a cult what is the
chance that that set of beliefs and
traditions has uh is more beneficial
than it is harmful to adherence chances
are very very low but you know all all
the religions of the world that have
succeeded in uh protecting a population
and
facilitating its flourishing have
started there and all the myths have
started as just stories as well
so yeah i mean i do i think we need
different words though because cult does
also mean something you know different
and specific and there are plenty of
stories that don't have the capacity to
turn into mess so it's i would say this
is an imprecise mapping it well
i don't think so but i think it does
require
extra precision to get there because
somebody who imbues
a
cult with the capacity to advise that
person as if it were a religion that has
withstood the test of time
is making an error so the point is that
the negative
i didn't follow that the negative
connotation of the term cult comes from
the fact you wouldn't you wouldn't say
that a
a book that contained a description of a
potential a candidate religion was
itself dangerous it is the adherence to
it
that is to say people who ascribe it
uh with that kind of
potential
that kind of value in the present before
it has stood the test of time and before
it has been refined by selection in any
way are making an error they are
treating something with the capacity to
advise that it doesn't it is not yet
known to have
that that's fair i don't think that
addresses the question of how i mean i i
just i wasn't i'm not prepared for this
conversation i'm not remembering the
various technical definitions that have
been proposed for what makes a thing a
cult as opposed to some other small
organization and
uh i think that there are
qual characteristics of cults that are
not inherently found in religion well so
what i what i the part that's important
for the argument
that i'm making is that
the value of these things has never been
in their factual accuracy
right and this has tripped up
secularists who look at the factual
inaccuracy of many of these belief
systems and imagine it to invalidate the
whole project
rather than saying actually factual
accuracy was never the point
um what the point is prescriptive
how should you behave right and because
these traditions the ones that have
withstood the test of time i'm not
arguing that any individual one is good
or bad
right there may be some that are pure
bad
probably all of them have components of
both
but
the
point is
when you know as as i've argued many
times a literally false metaphorically
true idea is one that if you behave as
if it was true you do better than you
would if you behaved according to the
fact that it is false and so
in this framework you have the ability
to hand down ideas ideas that may be
factually in conflict with the evidence
have people behave as if it is not in
conflict with the evidence and for some
reason do better now what i'm arguing is
that cancel culture
is doing exactly this
cancel culture
wokeness is strangely indifferent to the
fact that what it claims is factually
true is so deeply in conflict with what
is well understood already and sim and
and observable by simple means simple
means right and so
this i think again this is trippy
uh we who are highly skeptical of the
woke revolution
are in some ways tripped up the way
scientific secularists are tripped up by
religious claims that are obviously not
right like the earth is six thousand
years old right
secularists are often
you know well
obviously it's not six thousand years
old years old therefore it is invalid oh
so the tripped up by by tripped up you
mean
we find the obvious falsehood
and we say that's all you need that's
all you need to know like we're done
here clearly this makes no sense these
people aren't serious they're not paying
attention to reality therefore can we
just stop already right and that's not
that's that's neither
um
it has been often discussed that that is
actually not the right way to dissuade
people who who believe a thing with you
know with with rationality and logic in
the face of a firmly held belief but i
think you're saying you're coming at it
from a slightly different perspective
you're saying uh this is going to be
that this is
ineffective in understanding what it is
because we're stopping too soon in our
analysis of it right we are we are
we're like people who want to drag a
geologist to a creationist and say
talk show the strata right show them the
strata show them just how long lived the
thing is and then they'll understand
that that thing they believe in is wrong
and the point is factual accuracy about
the nature of the dirt was never the
point right where the universe came from
was never the point where people came
from was never the point the point was
always how should you behave right now
the dangerous thing here and the thing i
want to distinguish right obviously
you know if i have to pick between uh
you know fatwas and stabbings and
being
maligned on wikipedia obviously i prefer
the latter right however
the one the ancient version is at least
about something now again i'm not
defending anything about it it's
absolutely vile that somebody uh
stabbed solomon russia you're trying to
explain it the same way you have tried
to explain the nazis
well yes but i'm also saying there is
something the fact that cancel culture
has some analogy in the sense that it
wants to fiat belief that it wants to
feed out beliefs that are in conflict
with
factual evidence and is completely
indifferent to the comparison between
the two yeah is about the fact that this
is some sort of brand new cult right it
has two things going against it one of
them is
uh it wants perfectly dangerous insane
things
and it is in no way tested by any
process
right
so
the point is it's like somebody came up
with this [ __ ] and now wants to hand
it down with the authority of god and
the point is the authority of god is not
about a deity the authority of god is
about the test of time and no time has
passed here right so what we're watching
is
a
cult of some kind of power structure
some kind of power structure that wants
the right to alter the most fundamental
things about civilization on the basis
of beliefs that are completely wrong but
it hasn't even demonstrated that it
knows anything that would allow it to
last a decade right nothing at all this
is actually um highly relevant to one of
the things i wanted to talk about which
i could insert here or i could i could
hold on that's your call
um let me just let me just insert uh
one of the things that i was hoping to
talk about it it's going to feel
very not in keeping but i know that
you've got
you're going to be able to return to
this
i ran into
this story
this week zack
what is the tampon tax 28 states do not
charge sales tax on menstrual products
this is on a site called usafacts.org
which is a site i had never heard of
before
which if you look
uh we're just gonna
we're gonna try
to
look at what they say they they believe
principles usa facts believes that facts
deserve to be heard
democracy is only successful when it's
granted in truth we're here to provide
that grounding with trusted government
data that's both easy to access and
understand we standardize data straight
from government agencies and present in
plain language with helpful
visualization so you can understand the
history of programs and policies
okay and they say a number of things
here about being comprehensive
understandable factual unbiased
contextual
i don't know about people-centric i
don't know what they
are claiming there but um and it's and
it's started by a former ceo of
microsoft current owner of the la
clippers i don't know why that's
relevant but you always see those two
things together with regard to this guy
um
oops i lost the oops so take away my
screen for a second sec
thank you
uh so the original article
here
that got me to this site what is the
tampon text
begins with this sentence about a
quarter of the u.s population are women
in the 15 to 49 age group and while not
everyone in the group needs menstrual
products
footnote it's an essential part of life
for many so just before i go to that
footnote i will say
the the question is one that may not be
of interest to many of our listeners and
viewers but it is it is a question about
if if you are one of the you know half
of americans who at some point in your
life are likely to end up needing
menstrual products
and this feels like a necessary uh this
this is there this is something that is
necessary that you did not choose that
is just part of what your life is uh
should that thing be taxed right and so
that's that's what these data are being
collated to to address like which states
do which states don't
but this footnote not everyone in the
group needs menstrual products the group
again being women in the 15 to 49 age
group footnote 1 well turns out these
people don't know how to write footnotes
because footnote 1 is irrelevant but
it's actually footnote 3 that they mean
here wow that's tiny too um for those of
you looking you can now see it says
women outside of this age group and
people of any gender who menstruate may
also need these products
[Music]
now
again this is this is on a site
usafacts.org
that has
described itself and indeed i will find
here the washington post interview
of this guy steve ballmer the zac you
can show my screen again if you want um
the washington post interview of the guy
who founded usa facts uh this is an
interview from 2017. it says again the
former chief executive microsoft and the
current owner of the la clippers
um
he describes himself here as
a
pro facts partisan
okay so he's trying to be clever here is
it pro facts partisan so on this site
which describes itself as many ways as
it can think to as being about facts not
about opinions not about caring about
your feelings not about you know
choosing an ideology it has snuck in to
the footnote of this article the idea
that
you are a woman if you say you're a
woman and that is going to mean that we
can no longer talk about basically
menstrual products being only for women
and it feels to me that this is very
much precisely if i may zach precisely
about uh the same kind of thing that you
are talking about here with regard to
sneaking in
sneaking in ideas
that are just bald-faced against what
everyone can see right it's
what you how you feel
how you want to dress how you want to
present
some people want to agree with this but
it's all good
but then claiming that how you feel and
how you want to dress makes you the
thing that you're not
and therefore causes a sight that claims
to be about facts and is being you know
was started and led by a so-called
pro-facts partisan to tie themselves in
nots writing footnotes that make no
sense at all
is a sign that we are not
in a reality-based universe at this
point it is exactly that that we are not
in a reality-based universe and what i
was going to argue as part of this model
is that you know we talk about these
things as virtue signaling yep um
i'm going to argue that whether that is
there is certainly an element of that
signaling your virtue to people what
these really are though more
fundamentally is shibboleths
right they are shibboleths yes and they
are shiva's and so imagine for a second
that a
shibboleth being
uh a word
uh that uh the pronunciation of which
can identify whether or not you are of
this or another tribe right so
the basic point is the word shibboleth
itself is arbitrarily the correct
pronunciation is arbitrary and somebody
who has just learned your language you
know a spy
may uh be able to read it and pronounce
it in some way but among the various
ways you know tribal shabolith whatever
you might say
my favorite one for whether or not
you're actually from los angeles or
but
it reveals
that you're not one of us and
the point really is
those of us you know us who are playing
the role of the secularists here looking
at the woke going wait a second
what you just said is so wrong i can i
can explain to you exactly why it's
wrong and we're completely missing the
boat and the point is really the wronger
the better because what you want if
you're gonna just flick this stuff on
doctors for example right you want 17
things that doctors now have to say that
they all know aren't true so that
somebody who's not really with you and
is just hoping this will blow over
reveals themself right you only want the
people who are you know will do anything
to stay in
and therefore will sign up for whatever
nonsense you've decided is medically
sophisticated i think i lost track who's
the you here which side is the you on if
you are the
revolution
like the woke revolution well woke is
one version of this but if you i don't
know if you are the revolution that is
going to use fiat
to hand down here is how you are to
behave
solomon rushdie
he is not an acceptable human being
anymore you are to accept that he is no
longer acceptable and that that has
certain consequences you are to accept
that these treatments are uh safe and
effective right your rolling is no
longer an acceptable human being right
if you are going to accept the handed
down from on a high conclusion about
who's in and who's out and what's true
and what's false and how we are to
behave right that's the point is that
this is either one or several cults
haven't passed the test of time that are
now behaving with the authority to make
us subscribe and anybody who doesn't
subscribe is cast out is punished all
sorts of things happen to them so some
sort of secular equivalent of a fatwa
and people therefore who don't get cast
out increasingly are accumulating
beliefs at odds with the basic facts of
reality right how can that be right well
this is how that can be and i would
argue that in one sense
the secularists are again
in some ways
at fault here because what's happened
is
it's this phenomenon uh apparently
various people have said this
the religion shaped whole
that to the extent that uh it is true
that religion is a product of evolution
that its purpose is not to tell you how
the universe works but to tell you how
to behave it is a narrative structure
that comes with uh prescriptive
recipes for well-being
and that the stories that come along
with it are at odds with the fact i
facts either because those who wrote
those stories didn't have access to the
facts right or because the purpose is to
be at odds with the facts in order to
figure out who's on board and who isn't
so what we are dealing with is a bunch
of
cults that are using an architecture
built into the human mind right
the desire to have somebody tell me how
it is that i should behave in a
confusing world and if that somebody is
an ancient tradition that has passed the
test of time then there will be at least
some wisdom in the prescriptions of how
to behave not in the facts as they are
described but in the what you're
supposed to do thou shalt and thou shalt
nots will carry wisdom
that is not the case for some brand new
cult that is handing down
uh pseudo-wisdom and nonsense stories
um by fiat backed by threat
right that's where we are
and
well it's not inherently the case so
your point is if it's ancient and it has
persisted there is likely to be there is
very likely to be some wisdom there
if it is modern
and therefore it has not stood any test
of time that that is all we know it has
not certain test of time and therefore
uh the near certainty that there is some
wisdom therein
is much lower well i'm going to go a
step further and i realize
you are correctly repeating back an
argument that i just made
a few minutes ago that we have to be
indifferent as to whether or not it will
stand the test of time in the case of
the modern
cults
i don't think we do these particular
active cults that are using this
religious modality to feed us
uh prescriptions by fiat power because
there is science
and we are able to look at the things
that we have been told about what we
must do and we were able to evaluate the
question of whether or not they did
function to our benefit right so for
example
the question of vaccine safety and
effectiveness which we were handed by
fiat these vaccines are safe and
effective right follow the science
that's what we were told
now
um
we can see that story
coming apart and so the fact that we
have been handed something that caused
people to harm themselves or to take
risks that they didn't need to take why
were children vaccinated with these
things if they stood effectively know a
healthy child stood effectively no risk
from covid why would they accept a
treatment that would expose them to
significant risk so
in this case what we have is an early
ability
the test of time has already proven
these things false i guess is what i'm
in some cases i mean i think it's
unfortunate it's too easy to go like
okay well here we're talking about this
one here we're talking about this one
this this is already this is already
falsified sure we got lots of these
things they're already falsified with
varying degrees of the recognition of
that falsification i will say though um
to interject again one of the things
that i wanted to get to ultimately
uh is that the cdc has updated its scope
guidelines and so let us just talk about
that a little bit here since since you
raised it um npr reports
um
npr reports on twitter
who knew um they say the update isn't a
huge overhaul of the existing guidance
but it does represent an increasing
focus on individuals making their own
decisions about their level of risk and
how they want to mitigate that risks
dr marcus plessia chief medical officer
for
i didn't look up what that is um so
npr's summary of the cdc's updated
guidelines and i'll show you the actual
cdc guidelines
shortly the summary has four bullet
points
those exposed to the virus are no longer
required to quarantine
unvaccinated people now have the same
guidance as vaccinated people
students can stay in class after being
exposed to the virus and it's no longer
recommended to screen those without
symptoms
the second bullet point is the doozy
right unvaccinated people now have the
same guidance as vaccinated people
well
isn't it obvious then that hidden in
that bullet point is we recognize that
effectively you are the same
that um these these things for which so
many people's lives have been destroyed
um and i'm not even talking about the
vaccine injured i'm talking about those
who have resisted and therefore have
lost opportunities have lost jobs have
lost family have lost friends have lost
all of these things
um are now it's going to just quietly
slip in oh by the way it's fine
never mind
not even in our bat though not even in
our bed hold on um
let me let me put up the actual cd cdc
document uh let me put it up in the pdf
form though so i can show so here's the
cdc document that
it's it's in yeah
um
this is from august 11th a couple days
ago
cdc summary of guidance for minimizing
the impact of covet 19 on individual
persons communities and healthcare
systems united states august 2022
they of course put out a lot of these
things but this is the most recent one
and if we scroll down to see vaccines
and therapeutics to reduce medically
significant
uh illness let me just make this a
little bit bigger for those reading
along at home except that doesn't really
work
um yeah that doesn't really work so i'm
just going to have to you're just going
to have to squint
covered 19 vaccination they start by
saying cover 19 vaccines are highly
protective against severe illness and
death and provide a lesser degree of
protection against asymptomatic and mild
infection
then receipt of a primary series alone
in the absence of being up to date with
vaccination through receipt of all
recommended booster doses provides
minimal protection against infection and
transmission
being up to date with vaccination
provides a transient period of increased
protection against infection and
transmission after the most recent dose
although protection can wane over time
that is a huge admission
and it's not that suddenly there's a lot
new a lot of new data out or there's a
lot of new um
analysis of existing data no this is
these are things that we have known
and
i don't know what prompted this report
now but what we are seeing is
we are we the cdc are going to put out a
report
that allows that allows those
organizations who have been listening to
us as if we are the law which they are
not
uh to start treating the unvaccinated
like full people again
while acknowledging that actually these
vaccines
what do they say provide minimal
protection
and provide a transient period of
increased protection
which wanes over time
so
i agree with the interpretation uh that
you put on it this is a tacit admission
yes right
what it functions as though the whole
point and again
long time viewers and listeners of
darkhorse will remember discussions in
which we talk about the fact that
sometimes
the
correct narrative
emerges in the end but what must not
happen from the point of view of these
power players is that they must not
vindicate those who were right about it
at the time so they do not go back and
clean up the record this is a perfect
example of that and i would say
that
what they are doing
maybe catholics will bristle at this
but you know again this is not an attack
on catholics what they are doing though
is effectively doing this by encyclical
right
they are simply updating the wisdom from
the oracle right the person with the
connection to god is telling us what the
new wisdom on the vaccines is and the
new wisdom on the vaccines is that the
vaccinated and the unvaccinated are
equivalent now right they're not saying
actually our old story fell apart so
violently that we are forced to
backtrack and you by the way probably
ought to figure out who was right about
that in the first place and start
listening to them because they had us
beat from the get-go they will never say
that
so what they're doing is simply updating
the guidance and you're only supposed to
care yeah about the immediate belief
structure of the thing that hands down
the instructions by fiat that's why the
encyclical works here
and
again
it is because whatever it is that has
captured the cdc
is functioning to
create something that fits a
religion-shaped whole a religion-shaped
whole is not about figuring the truth of
the universe it's about figuring out
what am i to do
right and what am i to do is oh i am now
to start treating the vaccinated and
unvaccinated equally which of course you
should have done all along right what's
more it lags
the reality right
it does not pay any attention to the
accumulating evidence that in fact these
vaccines have been harmful right have
actually crippled people's immunity it
completely ignores the fact that even
the data that they use to argue
that these things
have some substantial effect that yes
wanes over time ignores the fact that
they create a vulnerability when you're
first given them right so
this is all you know coming down this is
this is oh by the way there's a burning
bush on that mountaintop over there and
i spoke with it and i came down with the
new wisdom about how it is that we are
to behave and you're never going to
believe this but i know that we were we
were busy scoring and throwing out of
our homes and our theaters the
unvaccinated but uh as of now uh we're
gonna stop doing that yeah right we yeah
we we encourage you to stop doing that
and you know i was for a while on a
weekly basis checking for with for
instance the local theater companies you
know who who's gonna let us in
and uh i just i gave up a couple months
ago i was like i'm i'm done you know
these these people are insane and they
don't understand anything about reality
or science and they're just never going
to let people who didn't take the jabs
back in and it turns out that quietly
without you know without some of us
noticing i just got told yesterday oh
yeah actually um at least here in
portland oregon suddenly
um
most of these places are are leading in
the unbacks and they can aren't checking
aren't asking for negative tests all of
it
and you know again
the question that you know i'm stuck on
and i know that this is exactly part of
what you are what you were talking about
like i'm stuck in like what changed what
happened guys what what happened in your
own head
and for the most part people don't
operate that way you know i want to know
what happened and i want accountability
and i want some damn apologies
at the societal level and i want this to
never happen again
and instead what we see as well what the
cdc said but oh well it's just a oh
it's a lot of mumbling and a lot of like
footnotes and uh and whereas
just if you would uh
put on my screen for a moment zach again
a tweet
from someone i don't know i don't know
who this is politically homeless too is
what they call themselves
a thread regarding the news of the cdc's
new guidelines in no particular order i
was not allowed to volunteer at my kid's
schools for over a year because i wasn't
vaccinated
a family refused to carpool with us
because they said they were
uncomfortable with their son sharing a
car with us we had been ratted out by a
mutual friend who said to the other mom
well you do know they aren't vaccinated
right
we were uninvited to good friends to
share a vacation house with them a
long-standing tradition was ended over
medical choice they all got covered
anyway of course
my daughter couldn't attend a theater
production with your school's theater
company because
denver center rules 50 of the
restaurants so many businesses in our
neighborhood were off limits to us i
won't forget which ones i'm just going
to read this because this mat like we
don't have any of these precise stories
but it's it's a freaking match for so
many people's experience
we had to eat ice cold lunches out of a
backpack huddled outside with frozen
hands and we skied at vale resort
because we weren't allowed inside the
lodges i could never get warm
i bailed on the rest of the season after
just two days of my pass wasn't worth it
i wasn't allowed to stay in a hotel or
eating any restaurant for a work trip to
dc i had to cancel all together as it
made travel there impossible
my husband having trained already for
six months was banned from participating
in an ironman event
a group of his friends told him over
text that he was endangering them and
their families and they told him he
couldn't stay in the airbnb with them
for and they told him he couldn't stay
in the airbnb with them for a trip they
had been planning they no longer speak
to him
i was called a conspiracy theorist by
dear friends and was left in the dust by
them socially i would have given one of
my kidneys to these friends they cut me
off after a wax that didn't stop
transmission or infection
my teens experienced unbelievable
amounts of stress
we didn't book a trip i was disinvited
my husband was fired so yes and goes on
and on just i alighted some of that so
yes i am seething a bit right now having
read the cdc's new guidance knowing that
this is what the guidance should have
been all along minus the
minus the ridiculous masking i want
apologies and i want assurances that
this won't happen again i know that
won't come though
this that thread speaks for a tremendous
number of people and
those
even those who became skeptical
uh who didn't get boosted who did their
first shot or first two shots and then
said no actually no more i'm not seeing
it
this set of experiences is invisible to
to a majority of americans at least and
i think in most the weird world and that
invisibility means it is more likely to
be able to happen again
yes
i
of course share exactly your
sense of ire and your desire for an
apology because of course an apology
would involve some power to prevent it
from happening again and exactly
reference the apology exactly none of
that has been conveyed here right now of
course again that is perfectly
predictable that it would go through
this so the real question is those of us
in our position how do we push the point
and say
not good enough not nearly good enough
and
here's the never again problem okay we
had a system
in which reality was right arrived at
through processes journalistic processes
dialectic processes scientific processes
that's how western civilization works
they
bypassed the entire thing they
decapitated it and they handed us down
directly as if they had gone up a
mountain and talked to a [ __ ] burning
bush they handed us
directly
you know as if from god here is the
things you are to believe and to act
upon they were wrong they did tremendous
harm and they brutally punished those of
us who stood up and said you couldn't
possibly know what you're saying the
mechanisms to know do not exist you are
lying if you are claiming to know these
things because you couldn't even if your
conclusions had been accurate you are
lying and claiming that you can know
these things when they claimed to know
them because they couldn't possibly have
known them at the time and i love the
metaphor of decapitation here because
then what they did is they took the head
no longer attached to the system of
science to the dialectic to the process
by which we actually come to understand
truth they stuck it on a stick and they
put it in front of us and had it jaw off
at us and a lot of people believed it
said okay that talking head
must represent science and truth and
reality and democracy it must well and
they also
they used a
childish cartoonish uh mechanism built
into the minds of many people to trigger
this i mean remember how anthony fauci
became anthony fauci to all of us in the
public who didn't know who he was
right
he was the guy who had his head in his
hands next to trump listening to
you know trump be unscientific at the
podium yeah that happens trump got some
stuff right and he got some stuff wrong
but the fact is anthony fauci was
visually in the minds of people the
mental alternative to trump which is why
he was imbued with uh
effectively a divine
sense of truth about him
which has well known it was also
as it turns out as you just said trump
got some stuff right and he got some
stuff wrong
as
covid was emerging in that spring of
2020 and he was trump was being his
usual blustering
off the cuff
pain in the ass
bombast
it was really easy to think oh my god if
only we had someone who knew what they
were doing and you could see
you could see some of the stuff that he
was just getting wrong and some of the
stuff's like no
could you not right and so to have
someone who appeared to have
you know the premature of science and of
history and of sobriety and of you know
just he was he was there in his own
recognizance and he knew what he was
doing to be to be to be in that sort of
face plant like oh i'm so dismayed to be
working for this man it felt like the
antidote and because it was easy for
many people to think
if not for trump we'd have this thing
kicked we'd we'd
we'd know what to do and this would be
over already obviously it was going to
be fouchy was the answer right yeah and
that visual impression of the sober
scientific dweeby but highly competent
alternative to the bombast who reads
stuff on the internet and can't keep it
to himself right
that thing was architected and it you
know yeah
just so happens that the sober
alternative happened to be a guy one of
a tiny number of people central to the
process of bypassing the gain of
function
research ban
and offshoring the work to the very lab
that likely released this thing right
it's almost beyond uh it's so
preposterous it's almost beyond uh
plausible no you would have taken a few
of those characteristics out of the
screenplay because it wasn't going to be
it's too much it's too cartoonish
but i mean actually can we play the uh
the video of uh watch out you were
watching a video of anthony fauci um
earlier this week at the fred
hutchison cancer center in seattle
speaking kind of off the cuff it's
interesting
well
you can't hear him so
let me tell you what he said okay okay
it's only it's like a 50 seconds yeah
it's a 50-second thing most people have
probably seen it already but
please tell them what they said without
actually um
adopting his voice or his anniversary
i'm not sure that i can recover from
that
oh okay we're gonna okay try it again
it's in the middle
um
okay all right skip it
sorry about that
anthony fauci uh and i will not imitate
him for
uh marital reasons for marital reasons
because i don't know if what he's got is
contagious but um
anyway he just would never be able to
look at you the same way what he
effectively says with uh
obvious uh glee ugly delight pride all
of the you know i don't know how many
sins are involved but um i don't think
there's any gluttony
i'm sure there is um but uh
anyway trim
oh
the dude uh you know he's diminutive but
uh he cuts a fine figure but
anyway
um what does the man say he says that
apparently there's something dubbed the
fouchy effect so far as i can tell he
dubbed it the [ __ ] effect but um
something called the fouchy effect in
which people are
uh
they are applying to medical school um
because
his uh scientific competent
blah blah blah modality has inspired
them to take up um medicine
uh
by his model or something like this
which
because he says i fashion symbolize
integrity and truth
not to me he doesn't well that's what i
just looked up the the little little the
little blurb that what what actually
does he say the fouchy effect
more and more people going to medical
school he claims uh is because he
symbolizes integrity and truth
especially and i think i'm paraphrasing
here in this era of misinformation he
invokes january 6th
uh yeah he invokes a range of things
from january 6 to whatever
yeah
my god it's been i mean it really it's
like it's 52 seconds it's quite quite
interesting but he really crams a lot in
there it's the it's the equal of that
one where he said that he was science
yeah yeah and you know yeah it's so much
the man you know the wizard behind the
curtain but um anyway point being this
is the structure that decapitated the
thing that we the messy thing that we
used to have that figured out what was
true medically speaking and what wasn't
true and what to do about it um they
just supplanted the whole thing yeah
they got between your doctor and your
pharmacist something that is
unprecedented right and they just
started handing down these uh these
encyclicals that
changed the behavior of our entire
medical establishment and anyway i
wanted to point out a couple things
about this right so they're functioning
in a religious modality
they've i would argue tapped into
the religion-shaped whole issue that is
especially open for those people who are
secular
right which is going to be a higher
number of people on the left which is
part of why this is going to be more
effective high number of people highly
represented in science
but in any case
um
this is part and parcel of a radical
shift a radical revolution that is
taking over the entirety of the west
right what they've done
is they have begun to hand down by fiat
a description of
the truth right remember when they tried
to tell us
that the virus couldn't possibly have
emerged from the laboratory in wuhan
that was just a simple matter of well
here's the truth and we're handing it
down well there's i mean they're still
doing that i mean there's a recent
christian anderson paper that we
referenced a week or two ago yeah
they're still there they're on that
they're also sorry i know you're on a
roll here but um the cdc guideline the
new cdc guidelines also kind of obscured
the fact that now
yeah natural immunity is is real and
it's just as good as vaccine induced
immunity it may last longer right so
what hello again what did you say
because weren't we fighting over this
that you know there we were scientists
were being scoffed at for claiming that
natural immunity could possibly be a
real thing that having had coveted you
might actually have immunity and
therefore not have to submit to the you
know also formulated in the lab version
of the immunity right that came
via syringe and in fact you have
the oracle from on high handing down
uh factual claims like natural immunity
is uh does in no way obviate the need
for uh
vaccination you have it participating
with
social media labeling
things that are true
as false you have the
the
department of homeland security
declaring
three kinds of falseness terrorism one
of which literally involves truth
which is inconvenient for government and
causes distrust of it right the whole
thing is about look here are the beliefs
you will now subscribe to their
relationship to reality is not the point
and anybody who feels an obligation to
reality is about to out themselves
because they're going to be forced to
mouth certain truths that are simply
false right the labels are going to be
reversed right this is all a matter of a
cult inflicting its new belief system
all of a sudden and it is going after
truth that is to say there is no major
journalistic establishment that is
independent of this
the university system itself is mouthing
the shibulus right history is being
rewritten by the same oracle-based
mechanism
right the the 1619 project
etc we are simply taking a version of
history that serves an ideology and we
are imposing it over actual history
we have the guilt and innocence of
people being a matter of uh encyclical
as well right so the raid on mar-a-lago
is supposedly justified by the fact that
this is the most law-breaking president
in history that's why we get to go after
people the way you know developing
countries used to you know political
factions used to go after each other
really what's he been convicted of right
the the so uh and even just the goodness
and badness of people right and this is
this is another place where the rubber
meets the road
human beings
because we have been forged by lineage
against lineage competition we are wired
for that just the same way we are wired
for religion we are wired to want to
know who's on the team and who isn't on
the team this is something that the west
did the best job yet of getting past and
is now being uninvented we have returned
to a place where we're supposed to
figure out oh who are the good people
and who are the people who are my enemy
right we are not supposed to say we are
all americans for example right and we
are united by that even over if we
differ over policy and what the wise
direction to go would be we are
americans first right no no the question
is who's good and who's bad right and
you know yeah sometimes that's the
question of you know who's jewish in
this case it could be a question of
who's vaccinated right but the point is
these things are all being handed down
by the same mechanism which is being
imposed over the superior mechanism that
the west yes it never completed the
project but the west innovated and
developed in which we had another method
for figuring this stuff out like
falsification right like um you know
collaborating on a project even if we
disagree over the particulars right so
we are being returned to a previous
world without the benefit of the
narrative structure or ideology having
passed through the test of time and at
least being
valid in some sense right it's valid in
no sense it is in fact in direct
conflict with reality in a way that
causes people who follow it to do
very rapid self-harm right so this is um
i think this is becoming really clear
and if you are shocked by the attack on
solomon rushdie you should be equally
shocked that a different flavor of the
same is taking over western civilization
and replacing all of the mechanisms that
have stood the test of time the only
alternative we have to that team-based
modality that is being replaced by
something in which
some oracle is going to decide
what you need to do what you need to
think who you need to attack and the
fact is there's just there's no future
in this
there is no future we cannot play those
games with the kind of weaponry at our
disposal we cannot play those those
games with the number of people on the
planet we cannot play those games with
the amount of industrial power at our
disposal this is just a fatal proposal
it is and uh
it doesn't
seem to be coming from one place you
know one of the things that i think
often
now is boy wouldn't it be great if we
had a president
uh now i don't i don't know who
could be president at the moment who
would be standing up in in the various
ways that such a person would need to
stand up but certainly having someone
who is has been m.i.a since before he
attained the presidency
it's not a good moment for that
and
one thing that
we have been observing since before
coven and uh
which was not really observable which
couldn't be seen by many who like us saw
the problem in the academy but weren't
scientists and so couldn't see the
problem within science
is
science
the process of science has become so
market driven
and so much about money and so much
about who you know
and therefore both a social and a
financial process rather than a process
of discovery and of understanding what
is true
that
it
it is now a game it and therefore it is
game while bull and so i think i will
save for another time
a discussion i wanted to talk a little
bit there's a
um
there are just a number of stories now
of
uh important impressive scientists or
important impressive scientific findings
on which lots of things are based
be it ocean acidification
or the alzheimer's research
where oh as it turns out just flat out
fraud
we just made up the data
turns out
now kudos in the couple of
cases that i just mentioned to the
whistleblowers who said ah no uh uh this
is this is not how science works
but for each one of these things it is
discovered
for on which basis someone's reputation
is made and therefore their career is
apparently guaranteed
how many are not discovered
how many of these of these scientific
findings that we are basing our
understanding on
are actually
one person one flawed human being who at
some point dreamed of being a scientist
presumably with all of the best
intentions and then found themselves
again instead in a social game and a
financial game and made one then a
couple then a series of extraordinarily
bad decisions and through science
overboard and
now we have a scientific record this is
far outside of covet but of course covid
puts this all under very sharp belief
that
you can't look at and know what you're
seeing
because when are the when are the data
actually the data we don't know we don't
know anymore the the the level of fraud
that we are now hearing about in science
is extraordinary and of course that's
going to be a tiny fraction of what is
actually going on hey tiny fry i mean in
fact it's an exact analog to the uh
the
p hacking apocalypse yes uh in
psychology yes
um
what i mean by that i will tell you i
was railing against p values
um
long before p hacking
had come to public attention
it's inevitable
that you will have this development
based on the fact that you have so much
at stake
in who succeeds in finding a pattern
that they can publish and the process is
obvious if you understand statistics
well enough to be doing these sorts of
tests you can see how you would do it if
you didn't have integrity well even
inadvertently right even inadvertently
but
if nobody if nobody publishes the
studies that come out in
significant you have a survivor body so
the system can do it inadvertently the
system can do it vertically a scrupulous
person can turbo charge it yes and the
point is
is there any reason to think that that's
limited to psychology no i guarantee you
it will happen in every field in which
statistics play a prominent role what's
more what you're describing
is inevitable based on the fact that
this is in effect a realm of
science done by the honor system and it
is not that science done by the honor
system is implausible it can be done by
the honor system but not with the system
of incentives with the system of
incentives deployed the way they are it
is inevitable that people who are really
good at cheating will rise rapidly and
people who learn how to coordinate
across a discipline and cheat will rise
rapidly and so this is going to be an
epidemic and it in part explains how it
is that our system was decapitated
because the fact is it was very feeble
it was in a compromised state based on
um the fact that fraud will have played
a major role in bringing us
um
to where we are yes
that's that's all exactly right
and uh and what a
what a precipice honestly
what what what a crazy precipice to find
ourselves on at um looking over it and
and
to return to some of the earlier points
to be looking around going like
you guys could see right you guys can
see that we're at eclipse edge
and many people are saying i don't what
are you talking about we're good it's
all good
you cannot go to the restaurants right
so it's fine right which to me sounds a
little bit like uh sorry we jumped the
gun jews are now welcome at the
restaurants and it's like okay i
remember not being welcome there last
week and uh okay it's all well and good
that i have more restaurants to choose
from this is we like the salad there but
but now i know
now i know what you're capable of
and uh frankly i'm not going to those
restaurants
right i just the point is okay you've
announced what team you're on and the
fact that your team is playing nice this
week is irrelevant to me you've told me
you've told me who you are i will say
too with regard to um i haven't gone and
looked at the various restaurants
because i think some of them are also
lifting their their vaccine mandates
here in portland um but on the at the
theater sites uh there's always some
fine print and it's actually the same
font size as the regular but it seems
like the fine print that they kind of
don't expect you to read which says we
can of course uh reverse this reversal
at any time um if if guidelines change
guidelines guidelines from whom on what
basis if someone anyone walks in and
says i have guidelines oh okay right the
guidelines have changed therefore nope
not you so what they are is saying uh we
are on team encyclical
right so the encyclical has it of course
we're going to follow the the cdc wisdom
because you know it's the cdc after all
but of course you know
you know we're going to follow the
current cdc wisdom and nobody can tell
you that except the oracle you know what
it's going to look like a month from now
so yeah there's that not fortune tellers
are we
writing
all we can do is follow the cdc right
well no not when and this is really the
important point is
you do have a choice
right yeah the cdc has been wrong
the entire time right it's been wrong on
essentially every major issue if you had
done the opposite of what it suggested
you would have been far better off
um yes go to the beach
don't get back definitely go to the
beach do get yourself some ivermectin
some hydroxychloroquine
right get your d get your d right all of
these things so
the last point i want to make is what is
your real choice if the cdc is now
functioning by oracle and encyclical
right and anthony fauci is the reason
everybody's going to medical school and
that tells you exactly what kind of
doctors they're going to be does that
mean he's both science and medicine i
think it does hmm yeah yeah that's uh
that's the big too that's a lot of
weight on his rather small shoulders but
um
anyway
i don't think there's any reason to talk
about his this size there's so many
reasons to rail against anthony fauci
he's a giant there's no question about
it
no i mean that he is a giant he's a
giant threat to
our medical well-being but nonetheless
here's the thing
in this process it was necessary for
this oracle
encyclical
fatwa
cancel process the one that declared
mal information to be terrorism and then
in the fine print said oh mal
information are true things that cause
you to distrust your government right
that's your department of homeland
security
it was necessary to target people who
were using some other process spotted
the cdc guidance as nonsense
and we're speaking about it openly
basically trying to use the process that
western civilization naturally does use
right
i don't know if you saw but alex
berenson talked this week about
information that he came by through a
discovery process
um i mean legal discovery yeah
in which the white house
had effectively
overtly pressured twitter to throw him
off
right by name
right now that is a blatant violation of
the first amendment
but it also tells you something about
what's going on you've got
wanton disregard for our constitutional
rights you have active antipathy for
journalism and anybody committed to
engaging in it we have seen the very
same thing targeted at us over engaging
in science openly
and
but this is effectively the declaration
of
heresy
right this is the targeting of apostates
this is the same mechanism as that fatwa
stuff
right it did not involve the literal
attack the physical attack on alex
berenson but it does is involve an
attack on the ability of people to
interact in polite society the ability
to earn a living
the ability to distribute
the product of your work in public
right this is an attack on something
very fundamental and concrete even if
the attack is more abstract than an
attack with a knife
and
you know
alex berenson suffered that we have
suffered it joe rogan has suffered it
obviously uh pierre cory all the doctors
robert malone
ryan cole all the doctors yep right um
so the point is what can you do if the
cdc is now a um what would the word be a
publisher of
uh pseudo-wisdom from the oracle
what can you do well a
you will know that the people who do
know to the extent that they exist are
amongst the heretics and the apostates
how will you know which of the heretics
and apostates
are
actually capable of
doing this kind of work and which ones
are
truly
uh
cranks
predictive power yeah you will follow
science right the scientific method says
you should be interested in those
apostates to the extent that they have
been ahead of the cdc that would be very
interesting how are they doing that what
mechanism are they using what um you
know physiological models are they
acting based on right you should put
more and more stock in people who have
predicted accurately ahead of time
garrett vandenbosch for example
so you do have a choice it's not a good
one and we have to restore a system
where institutions can function but in
the absence of it you are not flying
completely blind you're going to have to
actively seek out those who have made
sense and have been revealed to be
accurate by the test of time
yes and i think um
i mean that was maybe we should just end
there but
one thing that that reminds me of
is
when you talk to people who are taking
the guidance from on high listening to
the encyclicals and the oracles and such
they will often say well i can't see the
future can i i wouldn't i don't know
what's going to happen i'm just i'm just
going to have to do whatever they tell
me to do at some level and usually they
won't say it quite that clearly because
that sounds too much like they're
following like they're acting like sheep
but it is in fact what they're doing
and
there really does seem to be a belief
among those who
many of those
specifically who have no background in
science that
predicting the future is akin to magic
like you there is there is no knowing
what's coming is there and of course
predicting the future is exactly what
scientists
do
you know not
globally necessarily you know within
some within some within a confined
domain that they have established as
this is the observation that i made that
i'm not trying to explain
and i've got these hypotheses that i've
generated and now i'm figuring out which
of the predictions what predictions i
can formulate for each hypothesis that
if true must demonstrate that that
hypothesis is false
that is
a form of predicting the future
and
when people say well i can't i couldn't
possibly know what's going to happen
next can i
you think well maybe you should either
start honing that skill yourself or at
the very least start thinking about
who among the people whom you could be
listening to seem to have that skill and
maybe pay them more heed than those who
consistently get it wrong
because the cdc seems to be playing the
role of of the oracle of the encyclical
of the that organization that will make
the future better than the past and yet
they are doing it wrong over and over
and over again
throw them out
stop listening to them well i want to
make one further point that you could
spot this
as it emerged based on one unavoidable
tell
science even when done
beautifully by people who are really
committed to the search for truth above
all else
is
messy
right as it emerges there is always
conflict over interpretation of a
particular result there is always the
revelation that certain results don't
mean what they appear to mean because
the methodology used was not robust
there's all sorts of noise and so the
point is what we when we say science we
mean a bunch of different things
to the extent that we sometimes mean
that which science has discovered right
that is one legitimate use of the term
science
we do not mean what did it discover this
morning
we mean what that it has discovered has
stood up well enough that when you build
it into a model you get smarter and not
dumber
right now my point about the cdc and
everything that functions as a part of
that pseudo church
is
there was no process
right the process that would have been
necessary for them to arrive at
conclusions that were worth anything at
all would have been a process of
discussion
there would have been evidence
that did have noise and conflict and
instead what we were done what was done
was we were assured
that that process had taken place
privately
by
companies with a conflict of interest
that the evidence that came out of it
was very very clear and that we would
know that as soon as we were able to see
it 75 years from now right they tried to
hide the freaking evidence and the point
was well do you really have a process
that's trustworthy because it sounds
like maybe you don't and you just want
to tell us the prescription that comes
out of it well there's another piece of
this i mean we could we could go on
forever here but there's another piece
of this too which is the sense among the
elites and as again long-time listeners
will know neither you nor i like the
idea of the elites right
it is the elite is trotted out as a way
to shut people up we are the elite we
know what we're doing the elite have you
know there's a special process by which
you can enter the elite and then you
earn the right to make decisions for
those who are not elite is is part of
what the the unspoken agreement is and
the elites
really have gotten used to being able to
say
don't worry about it we did the work you
don't need to see our work
here's our conclusion
accept our conclusion sit down shut up
take the jab it came from a
frozen ferret badger steak you know
natural immunity isn't any good
none of these pre-existing treatments
will help you just take our word for it
we are the ones with lab coats and the
fancy credentials and we went to all the
best schools and we know all the right
people we go to all the right parties
and if you don't believe us well that's
on you
and also we're not going to actually let
you make that decision for yourself
so
this is this is a kind of again hubris
that we find in every domain in
journalism in academia in politics and
every domain
but
we we saw this and i you know i'm sure
we saw this long before that but i
remember running into this attitude at a
very non-elite institution at evergreen
where many of our colleagues treated
students like this
you don't want to see how the work is
done i'm just going to give you the
conclusion so that you can go on your
merry way
and if there is a place where that has
if there is any place where that kind of
attitude should have no place at all
it's education education is exactly
where everyone who showed up should be
able to get their hands as dirty as they
want to get them
but one of the things i think that many
people have learned in the last two and
a half years
in uh with regard to kovid is
a lot of people
a lot of people are a lot more willing
than most of the so-called elites are
willing to give them credit for to try
to figure out what is true and what is
best for them and their families on
their own and they are done taking
so-called elite authorities at their
word that they actually have their best
interests in mind because most people
are actually capable of thinking for
themselves and want to do so
which
goes to the other the other tell
at the beginning of the pandemic
actually when you and i started doing
the dark horse live streams we were
fascinated to be looking into
the pre-print literature the
non-peer-reviewed literature yeah right
that literature was vibrant it was noisy
as hell as it was it was bound to be
it's been through no process other than
uh
you know
something about what captures your
attention because it's being discussed
or something along those lines most of
the work was
maybe not high enough tech but like
required enough of an infrastructure so
that it wasn't just rando's on the
street going like i'm gonna throw
something up for the pre-print server
right it was people people with labs
people with experience people with some
history working with viruses or
pandemics or you know
so it was professionals yeah but their
work had not individually been put
through a process
the point is what was high in that
milieu what was high transparency yeah
right not perfect you don't know that
people didn't uh you know fraudulently
write these papers based on no
experiment that had actually been run
but the point was it wasn't some hidden
selection process
right then you institute peer review
right the the the pros catch up and peer
review gets back on its feet and it
starts controlling what you see of what
was done there are weird reversals
papers that have been accepted for
publication being
unaccepted right the process has become
a whole bunch more opaque and then
there's the level of opaque at the cdc
which is effectively total we're not
going to tell you how we came to this
we're going to tell you that it's
evidence-based right and so i guess what
i would say is the very nature of this
process is that there has because of the
noise that is inherent to the generation
of actual evidence in in complex systems
there would have to be a process you
would have to see evidence of that
process to have any confidence that it
took place because otherwise if you can
pretend that there was a process and
then just hand down its supposedly
evidence-based conclusion then a cheater
will do that because it's obviously the
right it's the
efficient thing to do with respect to
getting people's behavior to change
without um you know
bothering to deal with the conflict
between what you're telling them to do
and the actual universe yes
that's right good
terrible but good
terrible but good uh yeah okay well uh
after a rather shaky start due to
problems mostly outside of our control i
think i think we got some good places
today yes here i agree um
we are going to take a break and we're
probably going to do a short q a this
week because we ran long and we have
a lot of stuff going on right after this
live stream today so once again we'll
not be here next week but we will have a
guest episode pre-recorded with brett uh
in this usual time slot we will be back
two weeks from now uh with another live
stream and a q a
at that point the private q a that we do
once a month will be almost ready to
happen so i encourage you to go into my
patreon in the next couple days
and join if you haven't and
and see if you want to ask a question
for that private q a
brett's patreon is also live and
thriving and the discord that you can
the discord community that you can get
access to at either of those is um
really quite vibrant go for it um check
out the norman fenton discussion i
had on dark horse has that been released
yet oh that's saturday oh my goodness i
have aired
grievously yes so that's what you will
have access to a week from now it's
pretty great i think you will really dig
it when we are not live next week nobody
can stop you from achieving greatness
right or fighting the power and i
suggest you put at least some of that
time
into those two activities so uh you can
ask your questions at
darkhorsesubmissions.com
right now
emailing logistical questions to
darkhorsemoderatorgmail.com
and
until we see you next time which might
be in a few minutes and it might be a
couple weeks be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]
you